i thought i had to
know everything in advance i thought i
had to be the authority coming in i
thought i had to be you know i couldn't
confess to not knowing something i was
reluctant to ask too many questions
because i thought that would
what mistakes did you make directing
your first episode of television
yeah that was uh early in my career i
write a chapter about it in my book it's
the second chapter i call it the school
of hard knocks
i had wanted to be and i grew up you
know as a
i watched films in the 60s and 70s and
kind of loved the independent
cinema world and
you know really aspired that's what i
want to do i want to make i want to be
an auteur and my first job was a feature
film in 1984
uh stephen king's silver bullet
i'm not a horror aficionado but that was
that was kind of often the the uh
the way in horror films to get good
directing credits and um
and after i did that
uh
you know i was determined i don't want
to do a feature i don't want to do a
horror film for next i want my next film
to reflect more of my sensibility even
though i'm i'm pleased that it now seems
to have a kind of a cult following and i
enjoy people telling me oh that was a
film i really liked but i didn't want to
do more horror films and uh so i was i
went into you know trying to find
material i liked went into what they
call development hell on a couple of
things uh and i became i got in my own
way a lot i became so so
critical about
anything
anything that was offered that i didn't
really i wasn't very quick to attach to
things and because i wasn't terribly
experienced i wasn't offered the you
know the great scripts i was offered
things that really required work
and
as i was developing material which never
wound up getting made
i was offered some television shows and
i thought of television well television
this was in the mid 80s and uh you know
at that time the so-called golden age
hadn't hit
the second one of course the original
one was the live television age but you
know and and so it really wasn't i
didn't take it very seriously as an
artistic form but i took i said okay
well maybe i can take some of this work
to just develop my chops as a director
you know
and uh
one of the first jobs i was offered was
miami vice in its third season and that
was the cool show and it's interesting
too because miami vice which was
spearheaded by michael mann
was was a bit snobby about who they
hired as director they only wanted to
hire feature directors which i qualified
for because i had that feature but what
i knew about directing then compared to
what i know about directing through
directing series television was like a
thimble compared to an ocean and
but still i was hired for the job
and i came into it uh
with all kinds of ideas that really got
in my way
one of which was i thought i had to
know everything in advance i thought i
had to be the authority coming in i
thought i had to be you know i couldn't
confess to not knowing something i was
reluctant to ask too many questions
because i thought that would somehow uh
erode my authority
and i and i
i even i kidded myself i lied to myself
about things and i so i didn't first of
all do as much prep as i needed to do i
didn't really immerse myself in the
story i thought no because i had a kind
of romantic vision then too of what
directing was so you have to be open
creatively in the moment well
i've since found it to be most open in
the moment for me i have to be fully
prepared and then i can be free enough
to be open and trust the answers that
will come from me but then i didn't
think that
so i i started working on miami vice and
that was like
at that time don johnson was known as
the king of miami and uh he he was a
director himself and i was very new to
film language i didn't you know i didn't
have security about how do you how do
you
what my shot list wasn't never sure like
um screen direction and what shots do i
need to cut the sequence well and i'd
kind of you know come up with an idea
but when i'd show up on the set you know
don johnson would frequently say
no how about we do this and he talked to
the camera and he'd start walking all
over me essentially which was
humiliating but what was what was
equally challenging was that his ideas
were better which i recognized
so i constantly felt um well i'm i'm
okay so i felt my my my confidence
sapped and everything else
in addition uh i didn't know the way of
the world in episodic television and i
didn't really understand the inner
workings the inner politics of it all
and i was shooting in miami while the
producers the creative team was in los
angeles and i was communicating
everything that i wanted to do to the to
the line producer in miami thinking that
was equivalent to talking to the other
producers and when i shot a sequence i
won't go into the details of it but i i
fixed something that was problematic for
the budget
uh and the linebridge yeah great and
then when the producers saw dailies they
freaked out because i hadn't cleared it
with them and suddenly i became
a fair target because
part of that show is everybody was
trying to be cooler than everybody else
and uh
everybody was looking for a scapegoat if
it wasn't like a super cool
show and so i became a lightning rod
suddenly because i had i had done
something that hadn't been cleared and
then i made a neophyte's mistake i i
didn't haven't read the script carefully
enough and i misread
uh the transfer of a body from the trunk
of one car to the truck on another and i
had i missed it i had to go the other
way because it had made story sense in a
different way than what the writer had
imagined but i wasn't even conscious
that i was changing it i just misread it
i mean to this day i can't figure out
why the script supervisor didn't tell me
hey it's written this way
it's the other way but anyway uh and as
soon as that happened in addition to not
having shot
the sequence as it had been written
uh you know it was it was just a
horrifically uh challenging experience
and uh there were a few other things
that happened and and i didn't know if i
was ever going to work again in
television at that point i was still
more concerned with features but it was
it was
very painful and there were other things
about it that were difficult the episode
turned out well actually and it and it
gave me confidence that oh i do know how
to tell a story and despite no support
and despite my own uh
self-judgments and self-recriminations i
thought you know it works the
performances all were delivered the
story was told well but it was hard to
overcome those original impressions and
i didn't get another job for several
months because you know that was my only
reference and it wasn't a good one
and i the next job i got was on another
show that period called beauty and the
beast and that also was a popular show
and uh
it's interesting it was uh
for those of you it's a it's a retelling
of the story was uh ron pearlman played
a lion-like mythological character who
lived below the new york subways and
that was the underworld and linda
hamilton played the beauty in the upper
world and she would come he was i think
she was a news reporter and she would
come down and they had this intense
romance which was very romantic and uh
and the story i was given
was an interesting one because it was
about a young man who who
had a very intolerant
father single father and he was
miserable the father could not credit
the young boy's
interest in his own imagination
and
the the show runner of
beauty and the beast knew that i was
interested i don't know how it was he
knew that i was at that time
doing workshops and reading a lot of
robert bleis
work with men and uh and
his partner a mythologist michael mead
who still is doing great work up in
seattle but i was very interested in
initiation male young males initiations
and this story seemed to be right up its
alley and uh the showrunner actually
called me and said you're interested in
this let's let's work on this because
that's what this story is about and i
was very excited about it and i started
filming oh and i and i learned from the
experience with vice
that my problem was i hadn't been
willing to admit what i didn't know
i hadn't immersed myself in the story
enough so i could take full
responsibility for every aspect of the
storytelling
and and would develop a shot a shot list
and a way of seeing that i could defend
and not just be
a deer in the headlights when somebody
had another idea
so i spent my entire prep
overcoming my reluctance to admit what i
didn't know
asking if i could spend time on the sets
after hours on the weekends you know
even if it made me look like someone who
was it was their first job
and i spent and it was a real it was a
real epiphany for me because i i took
total responsibility for every moment
being communicated i lived on the sets i
absorbed them as if they were characters
themselves i acted out in my imagination
all the scenes i developed staging ideas
because i wanted i didn't want to come
in again not knowing and which starts
with admitting what you don't know
admitting what questions need answering
that's what i hadn't done on the first
job and it became very exhilarating to
me so that i emerged with a vision of
how to tell the story and then i could
enlist the help of all the collaborators
all they want to hear is what you want
to do and what what vision you're trying
to hold then they bring their creativity
and it was thrilling and i started
directing and within the first three or
four two or three days they really the
producers were over the moon they they
called me and said oh my god these are
the most beautiful dailies we've ever
had the performances are amazing
and on the i think the fourth day or
they came to me and said you know you're
the showrunner came to me and said you
know you're the director i most trust
our next episode is the most important
one can you do it
and i said wow i don't know i mean i'd
love to but it's a holiday let me check
with my wife and we can work it out for
our family and i said okay good and he
says great.
so i had about three more days of
filming and
about two days later there was some
shift that happened it was very bizarre
suddenly they weren't calling me
and and i shot a scene
for the ending of the show and the pr
the showrunner finally did call me and i
could tell he was furious at me
and i said what he's you didn't shoot a
close-up of the father
and i said well
we can shoot it tomorrow if you want it
but the reason i didn't is the story we
had discussed
doing in advance was that this was a
story of an initiation
and that the story not to get too
involved about it but the boy
travels to the underworld
finds an inner father who will bless him
who is embodied by ron perlman's beast
and it allows him to survive the
intolerant other father and and that a
key initiatory challenge is to develop
containment so the scene the showrunner
was asking me about is when he
re-emerges from the underworld and the
father is there to greet him with with
the battalion of firemen and police and
linda hamilton's character is also there
and the father embraces him who's never
touched him the whole episode he's just
been angry at him
the key moment is the look between linda
hamilton and the boy in the while he's
in the embrace of the father is he going
to
stay with containing what he knows
because if he reveals the existence of
the underworld it will be it's undoing
and so he looks at linda hamilton
she looks at him and they understand in
that moment that he's going to contain
this and so he's been blessed he's going
to he's on his way to manhood
and that was the story to cut to a
close-up of the father i thought would
muddy the his feelings were not the
appropriate thing so i said that's what
i thought the story was but if you want
us to get this other moment i will get
it tomorrow which we did and when i
finished the episode expecting to start
the next day on the on
the the following episode
i was told uh there's been some
rethinking about this
and you'll report to the showrunner's
office tomorrow and i felt like i was
being summoned to the principal's office
but what happened was i i showed up and
you know it reminded me of a scene i
don't know if any of your viewers saw
the movie network but there was a famous
scene when peter finch's anchorman
character comes in to meet with ned
beatty's producer character in a
conference room
and ned beatty just glowers over him and
says
do you know what you're [ __ ] with
that was that was the feeling i had that
was my god this guy starts telling me
and he's i remember his opening words he
says i was
seduced by your beautiful style and i
missed that you have absolutely no
capacity to elicit emotion
and i said what what's going on i said
because that was the one thing i'd never
been accused of i'm good very good with
actors and getting in and that's also i
was flattered because i didn't have a
visual plan in the previous episode and
now he said i had a beautiful visual
style so that was great
and i said what are you talking about
and something had shifted in him and he
had developed made a case against me
and what i came to understand is he had
gotten cold feet about his the whole
thrust of the episode we had agreed upon
going in
because you know it's interesting show
runners
get to inhabit a very exalted position
you know you really feel like you're on
top of the world you can even be a star
yourself as a showrunner and if your
show gets cancelled it can be like going
from the penthouse to the basement boom
like that and you could just join the
throng of throngs of unemployed writers
you know and i think he started to feel
like wait we're not giving our audience
the sentimentality the romantic
sentimentality we usually they tune in
for
and
and i said well and i i realized that
you know i understood this goes to an
earlier question you asked me it's like
what what the audience's expectations
were i i understood that that was an
element of the show and i i thought that
actually we were
enhancing the uh romance between lynn
hamilton and ron perlman's characters by
virtue of the fact that they were
playing surrogate roles surrogate
parental roles with this young boy and
they were bonding together as they were
doing that but the story
i was handed was not a sentimental story
it was a i thought a much more
tough-minded one and a much more
meaningful one and i think he got cold
feet i think he got worried that i
wasn't so hence the need for a
sentimental shot of the father at
exactly the wrong time
but he had made a case against me and
his producers who were just very slavish
to him you know were
supporting him and all that and he said
you even undermined the key visual stuff
moments in the show there are visual uh
uh highlights i said what are you
talking about and he said there was a
visual
uh
trick they use on every episode when
when you go into the underworld you walk
into the subway tunnels and you'd enter
what looked like a skylight but it was a
super bright light and as soon as the
character goes in they just would
disappear
and he said you didn't shoot that
and i looked at the producer who was on
set with me when i didn't shoot it and
he didn't say a word i said well the
reason we didn't shoot is the light
malfunctioned on the day
and i knew we have to come back at
expense great expense another time which
we could certainly do but i said while
we're here
maybe there's a way around it maybe the
boy could approach the light could be
photographed it's just when someone went
into it they wouldn't disappear so maybe
the boy could be moving towards it and
then we could cut to linda hamilton
watching him disappear as the audience
would assume he had and turn away i said
if it doesn't work fine we have to come
back we'd have to come back anyway but
if it does work we have it but he was
convinced i was actively trying to
sabotage him
so it was a crazy crazy experience and
now i'd had two terrible experiences in
terms of future references and i thought
am i ever going to work again and i did
finally of course get another job
several months later and ironically it
was with a showrunner who had worked on
beauty and the beast and didn't care at
all about what had been said because he
had been on staff there and had seen
these exact kinds of accusations leveled
routinely at other people himself
included you're undermining the show or
whatever so he says i don't i don't care
about any of that
and on this show uh
it was it was interesting i started
working on it i applied the same lessons
i'd learned from the need to really prep
and get fully immersed
i started shooting and on the second or
third day i got a phone message and i'm
listening and it says oh it was producer
director we love your dailies the
performances are great we just couldn't
be happier
and i remember i was in san francisco i
was walking to the set
and i just remember just dropping the
phone hey boy am i glad i had that
experience on beauty and the beast so i
know not to take any of that seriously
and i stopped myself thinking wow is
that really what i feel i'm glad for
having gone through that horrible
experience and i realized i was because
it had acquainted me with
uh
so much about the nature of these shows
and what the political
interactions are and sensitizing me to
that i mean if if they hadn't liked the
show i would have what i was doing i
would certainly want to hear about it
and i'd try to you know accommodate them
but i knew
that i wasn't going to be so dependent
anymore on you know
with someone else's opinion i'm not and
i'm not going to necessarily you know
assume i'm at fault or go into a dark
hole if a choice i've made isn't agreed
with
so that was that was big but what was
most important what i realized was that
the real gift of beauty and the beast
was the experience i had before it ever
blew apart when i knew to just go on the
set spend which i do to this day
just immerse myself in the story to find
out what i care about find out what
might need to be changed for me to care
about it more find out in advance what
walls might need to be made wild meaning
you could take it out when you're
shooting
away from it but put it back in when
you're shooting towards it giving you a
better frame
all of those things i learned to just to
and to just to be fully uh take full
responsibility for the storytelling that
was the real gift of beauty and the
beast and i've i've made use of those
gifts i think for the rest of my career
and so do you think that it's more
detrimental to the set
to have a director who yells
and is somewhat of a bully or
a director that
doesn't own
their authority
yeah
i think uh
set demeanor is is is a is a is a real
issue uh and one of the uh
requirements one of the realities of
being a director is that you're the one
in command and you can either accept
the responsibilities that come with that
except
take ownership of that role or
not now there's all kinds of ways to
take ownership of that there's all kinds
of ways to to have command and to
demonstrate command it does not mean you
have to be commanding
i think you know as i've thought about
it i wrote a chapter called interstates
in my book that addresses this among a
few other things
i think those who have command are those
who the the crew and the cast they have
to feel it within you there is a there
there
that you're taking responsibility for
the storytelling and that uh and that
the buck stops with you now
i think the best leaders are those who
are willing to acknowledge what they
don't yet know and are and are
interested in collaborating and are
interested in getting the best from the
people around them because you know
there are so many people that have
expertise that i as the director don't
have you know the director of
photography knows far more about about
light sensitivity and lensing and all
that than i do i have ideas and i'll
make suggestions but i i cut off my nose
to spite my face if i insist you know if
i don't if i'm not interested at least
in hearing you know another point of
view same with same with production
designers and and prop people and and
and
and uh you know wardrobe and hair all
these people what i try to do is
is carry a vision for what story
communicate a vision for what story i'm
telling where i think the emotional
reality lies where what subjective state
i'm hoping to create for individual
scenes communicate that without telling
necessarily how to achieve that and so
someone and then then you're enlisting
the creativity of everybody to come up
with ways i might never have thought
about you know
so
so how to get the best from your
collaborators is i think the mark of
getting the best from your collaborators
i think is the mark of a good leader
you know we all have insecurities we all
have our personalities we bring into it
one of the one of the
things that uh you know is a constant
learning for me and i you know earlier
in my career it was not something i
could always hold in mind is how much
people project onto you as the director
you know you're the authority figure now
you know
you probably experience yourself as the
flawed human being that we all are but
when you're in a position of authority
other people are looking to you and as
the director you know you have the great
great power to influence their own sense
of job security or even self-worth you
know if they project who knows what
they're projecting on you so
it's important to accept that role
and to be
and to be
i would say benign that's not to say i
mean that also means sometimes you have
to set boundaries you have to
hold people accountable it doesn't mean
you're always saying yes to everything
or it's a love fest you know sometimes
people don't measure up and don't don't
take responsibility for their own areas
they need to take responsibility for and
i think as a leader you need to make
that clear that you expect better but
you know when you are
abrupt and
you know dictatorial
you know it doesn't it doesn't make me
want to cooperate with that person and i
assume that's how others are going to
react and i think it also betrays an
insecurity that people at a deeper level
understand so which also makes people
uneasy regardless of how they're being
treated personally they don't feel
they're in good hands they don't feel
actors for example may not feel the
story is going to get told well because
this person is insecure and is just not
listening to me won't even hear it
they're too rigid
so
there's that problem and then there's
also the problem when you know when you
when a director doesn't take
responsibility you can always feel that
when you walk on the set because there's
a kind of vacuum there you know no one
really knows who's going to make the
decision
and that leads to an innervation and a
kind of you know
you don't get your the best from your uh
collaborators i think there's a baseball
metaphor i like which is you know
the
the pitchers with the best control
are the ones for whom the defense plays
better because they know like for
example if a batter comes up
you know i don't know if many any many
of you are baseball fans but like on a
diamond if you pitch someone if a
right-handed ears up and you pitch on
the outside the likelihood is going to
hit the ball more to the right side
they're not going to be able to get
around so if the infielders see that the
catcher is signaling for the ball to
come to the outside and they know they
can count on their pitcher to hit that
spot they'll gravitate more to that side
and be in better position to feel it if
the pitcher's wild and throw it anywhere
they don't know what to do
you know
so
you know
taking responsibility makes everybody
feel
feel
you know
i think more willing to contribute
themselves so long as the one taking
responsibility is respectful and
interested in what they the others can
bring
you mentioned the director's role in
being benign i think you used some
example of a francois truffaut yeah
film where there was a hearing yeah as
it related yeah yeah well director's
role yeah uh you know one of the things
that's that's not often spoken about is
uh and i haven't read a lot of the
literature that's been written about
directing but the that i the that
the ones that the books that i have seen
and also just the discussion generally
about directing and and when i talk to
young directors and the people
no one seems particularly interested or
aware
necessarily of the wide range of
emotional challenges that you face as
the director the stresses the
bombardment with questions the need to
come up with answers you know all the
insecurities and and different moods the
impatience you can get when something
isn't happening fast enough or
when an actor isn't understanding
something or you know it's like it can
it can
create such a wide variety of emotional
states
that one of the really important
qualities to develop is is i think of it
as mindfulness is willing as containment
is being willing to acknowledge what's
happening within you and still keep your
you know
see the forest for the trees and keep
your eyes on the prize and maybe a few
more cliches i could throw in but you
know to uh
to so so that there are these these
stressors as a director you know uh is
this good am i getting this oh my god
it's night time we are only on this
three more scenes the most important
scene is the end of the day and i'm
gonna have to rush it because i have
all these things you have to constant
prioritizing and always trying to think
and my way through by the way is to
always emphasize story that that's the
thing i have to focus on what's the
story point what's you know how if i
have to simplify something i don't want
to simplify i don't want to
lose a story point i might sac have to
sacrifice a beautiful shot that was
time-consuming
but getting a beautiful shot and missing
the story is not even a
consideration you know you gotta i for
me anyway you've got to keep telling the
story and um
one of the one of the one of the states
that i mentioned in my book that you
cite is that you know francois truffaut
brilliant filmmaker one maybe my very
favorite film director maybe my very
favorite film is the 400 blows buddha
souffle she made in 1959 which i didn't
see when it came out but i saw a little
after and it's a beautiful film
autobiographical film he made another
wonderful film several but one in
particular called la nui american which
was translated as day for night
and that's you know the term that a film
term when you you know shoot
a night sequence in the middle of the
day by stopping down the camera a lot of
westerns used to do that so when you see
a western and it's like it's night but
you're seeing everything across the
plain and everybody you know well you
didn't they didn't like that whole thing
what they did is they
they limited the exposure to the film so
that it would just look darker
so anyway that was that's a film term
but in day for night he played
he played a director of a film coming
together it's a wonderful film and one
of the things i love about it too is it
it really does capture the feeling of
what it can be like even on series
television when you when you've worked
for a period of time and you've worked
with various different crews and you
move around and crews spread out and the
makeup person from this show is winds up
oh and this new show oh i know you and
and the you know the key grip is some oh
yeah remember we worked on so this show
was great it showed everybody kind of
coming together in this whole world
getting created to create this film
and truffaut played the director and he
was dealing in this little sly twist i
thought you know everybody's coming to
him they're producing we don't have
enough money and he said okay we'll deal
with that and the actor's saying and i
just got out of the psychiatric ward and
i left him and his you know we have to
deal with that and okay i'm dealing with
that and then the star and it's like all
and everybody's coming in with questions
and he gave his character a hearing aid
so that he could just simply sometimes
just say i can't hear you
and it's like and i thought that was
really a great little twist because it's
like i i thought it just spoke to a
fantasy you know many director's habits
would be nice sometimes just tune it all
out just give me a break let me just
let me just chill for a minute but you
know the reality is the director's the
one person who can't be missing in
action